روسيا التي تتفادى الجلوس اعطت مفاوضات
فان الصين الشعبيه
اختارت غضب النظر عن التحاور بخصوص
التوازن النووي
اهتماما بخصوص هذه التغييرات لقوات
النوويه ولم نرى
نيه من قبل الصين الشعبيه المشاركه في
استقرار العلاقات
وبشان روسيا قال سالفن ان بلادها اتخذت
اجراءات للرد على خرق روسيا لمعاهده نيو
ستارت وان تلك الاجراءات ستتضمن عدم
استفاده روسيا من خروجها من الاتفاقيه
نحن لا زلنا
متمسكين بمحاسبه من يتهور فاستخدام
المتحده ستواصل التنبيه على
روسيا والتحذير من التجارب التي تخرج عن
اتفاق النووي ولكن يوم امس
اتخذنا اجراءات
للرد على خرق روسيا
لاتفاقيه نيو ستارت هذه الخطاه ستضمن
الا تستفيد روسيا من خروجها من اتفاقيه
ومبدا التناسب والمعامله بالمثل بخصوص
التوازن النووي
من جهه اقاله الناطقه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخاروفا ان الخارجيه
الروسيه تدرس تصريحات مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي بشان معاهده نيو ستارت وسيتم
الاعلان عن رد فعل موسكو عليها يوم غد
السبت